[music]
at the beginning of the current day, Ukrainian militants
violated the ceasefire four times
in order to protect the civilian
population, our defenders were forced to
return fire to suppress the
enemy’s firepower
[music]
to Russia, of course, we hope that no one but her will
help us at all no one  it won’t
help, but the only thing is that we’re just
giving us more, they’ll
get it so quickly we’ll manage it, well, Russia,
neither today nor tomorrow, as they say, she’ll
come in, of course she must come in
because there are a lot of Russians here, people
get passports specifically to
be safe to themselves  it’s just
to feel at least a little at least a
little to feel stable
[music] it’s
just kind of just really
stupid this can’t be who will go to
war
we or they are
the same people as and what
[music]
old age has come all my life about pounding
this is the most  old age at least already live
and normally they don’t give it like that, and whoever does
n’t tell the street with sperm over his guard said
you lie with one ear on the pillow and listen with the other it
doesn’t fly there that the noise doesn’t run
for 2 with might and main, well, in short, you need mersin
[music]